in the book this is impact Repertory
Theater everyone
but in the book I always talk about I
talk about the order of the feather rite
of passage fraternity Soyuz young man
these young men are candidates for the
order of the feathers so I think they
have a little something for us right do
they take it away good evening impact
Repertory Theater is a leadership
training and creative arts organization
we like to say when you combine and
activists in and an artist you have what
and what is impact what is impact how
come it's not a game the I stands for em
p a SI t and our credo is
from the streets of Harlem from schools
and community centers to prisons to
homeless shelters to the Oscars and back
home to New York City impact Repertory
Theater I wasn't born crip and I wasn't
born blood but when there was no hugs at
home the streets sold me love
Frankenstein made a monster American me
TV but I saw one thousand murders before
I was three I wasn't born alive hey no
outs there but all your values told me I
needed the riches to be real I had
Malcolm him morning but to sucking down
I tried to get a job and you said no
with a frown I went to crowded schools
with teachers who was stressed but when
I try to go to college they said that
was reserved for the best how wants to
play at the center you said the cause
was too high saw whence of the mountains
to dream and you let my dream died so I
asked for a moment to speak of the pain
you said stop act like a baby life's not
a game so I put on my headphones to
drown out the screams and ran me off the
corner for making a scene no present no
future no hope I can call even a mouse
which I'm vicious when it's the backs
against the wall I started like with the
smile but now i don't know maybe you
could tell me more two hours ago
midnight basketball games in the park
how about a computer in my bed in a
mentos with heart they say the goal
worth the struggle is a surprise that's
just right I'm the promise of tomorrow
it might not worth the fight I'm the
village that will grow from the child I
am your future injustice oh wow they say
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
Frankenstein made a monster
you make me more impact Cooper I me
chuck comeau pack who's mommy's like
this you're psycho psycho come on they
told me I shouldn't achieve my heart the
matter said that I shouldn't believe so
I wouldn't that could I shouldn't I try
don't even bother a treat for the pie no
the rain
yeah wait Robin her new
he came a shrimp will get through
changeup odd enough Randall want to say
thank you
hi
for no one has fun with this one
Oh impact was blessed impact was blessed
with the opportunity to write a song for
a great movie called August Rush and
then that movie impact played the choir
how many of you seen that movie so we
had the opportunity to go to the Oscars
and perform on the kodak stage we will
nominate it for the song raise it up and
we would like to perform it for you
right now ladies and gentlemen raise it
up
oh my friends keep on telling me but
they just don't understand this far too
many brushes in reality I'm dealing with
the patients Javier I gotta be myself
because there's nobody else for me know
sometimes it takes a different kind of
love to raise a child don't give up
sometimes it takes a different country
to make sometimes it takes another
humming hand to show the way don't give
up
that's imasu but i know i got the straps
and make it grew it out cuz i'm still
parents are breaking through this water
you
Oh different the child
Alan join the show so far okay cool just
quickly i want to thank brother or uncle
bullwhip that some of us call him for
teaching us as can't the chant and
hopefully it take Samiha down memory
lane and introduces the fuel y'all to
something very special now right impact
power power power power power to the
people power to the people's people's
power it's the people's power educate
and power education power gone toe in
power gonzo empower liberating power
liberating power power power power power
power to the people power to the people
people have a lot to say but what goes
on in the world see if your hey listen I
know you looking forward drop out right
now you live it in the past week right
now with me with a brand site now change
the world with the words me right yeah
he was no notion game come over you from
the school of hard knocks prepare my
colleges all up in your single man a
picture being evacuated for a change
through your head go a politics on the
street same as the world brother killed
panela focus on your pshaw you rather
build your clientele the chocolate
dessert
the government will load my key
ready sorry buddy buddy ready for for
this duel energy sorry buddy buddy do
that Oh daddy survived by you that
pitchfork into that gene survive like
Ken's missing to read cancer by the
bodies in bed damn plaque come on dance
into that game sorry buddy rich amber
come on this thing so that game sorry
buddy buddy brandon can pack come on
impact repertory theatre
young artists for us is hard to believe
but we want to share that this year is
our 15th year of doing this work and
that over 1,000 young people have come
through the program I have to bring up
and anyone who knows me the impact
family would not be here if it wasn't
for the love and the support and the
encouragement of some very very special
people before I do that Philippe Luciano
is in the house yes and a lot of people
work very very hard but in particular I
have to shout out Dean a marshal cells
who worked so hard on this and Daisy
Daisy doesn't get enough shout out Daisy
now she gets we have to get us a love
co-founder of impact Joyce Joseph come
on up
Alice all and please come I bet Allison
Sundance and so not only is she an
important reason the impact exists she's
the reason I'm a professional
screenwriter she had a screenwriting job
that was her job in her soul own it was
the story of Clarence Thomas and you
need a hill Anita Hill and she said i
don't feel right about doing this Alice
Alice had already been nominated for an
Oscar for Silkwood and she says well I
don't feel right doing this without a
black writer and there's only one right
I want to work with its jamaal Joseph
she's the reason I'm a professional
where's Uncle Ray Ray Jay Raymond
Johnson Ray Johnson in the house as I'm
calling the founders did you not think I
was going to call your name why are you
so far back Raymond Johnson courtney
Bennett all Kourtney has to come from
upstairs as I'm calling the founders is
you not we exploiting I'm seeing
movement courtney Bennett we talk about
mentorship the person who produced my
first play coming out of prison and we
have been friends and working together
ever since when you talk about the Black
Arts Movement when you talk about giving
young writers a chance but believing in
young people first and foremost the
person who is the reason why South
African theater came to United States
plays like a cinema Lee was the albert
and Sarafian abroad on broad Serafina on
Broadway the chair of the Harlem Arts
Alliance boza rivers
really quickly I noticed some impact
board members in the house please stand
where you're all of our board members
stand and now you still here come
represent the board now Rodgers where's
now allowed now now where's now okay now
come on up here what are you talking
about right and Kathleen cleaver now
there's a film called Public Enemy where
they yes sir Kathleen like mica yes
you're Captain cleaver we need you and
here's a film call our Public Enemy that
was done years ago by filmmaking
engineer and it follows the lives of 44
Panthers it was Bobby Seale Kathleen
cleaver now Rodgers and myself so on
behalf of the Bobby who's not here and
now who's a member of our board I wanted
you to see now under them huh yes that's
right ed to do one of the interviews
they said well what books are you
reading and i told them i was reading
dr. Maribel's book about Malcolm X and
nows book which is a brilliant book
which is called Lake freak now right
it's caffeine cleaning up
okay okay yeah I just wanted to say to
all of you that you just got a very very
small slice of what impact is in all
about so tomorrow in celebration of this
particular month black history month
they will be performing at the American
Museum of Natural History and the imax
theater at four-thirty tomorrow it can
see that over a thousand people so
impact is on the move so tomorrow if you
were in the the downtown area please
come to American Museum of Natural
History and see impact perform thank you
we're going to get ready to move to the
book signing to close it out impact
Repertory Theater and happiness Oh try
to spend every day tomorrow don't put
your hands together
because
I
today is the day that we can change
whatever but there's a joy of ever fall
for you when we receive it it shows Oh
what I right envision what I light light
you know I got something happen in real
life real light on i shore us wanna rock
man peace mother like my life
Oh
to be happy let's do the main impact
finally free change